hello and a very warm welcome to world
stories i'm laila horak with your weekly
international reporters magazine and in
this edition we had to Australia to
celebrate all things Scottish see how a
village in Tajikistan is trying to
improve its local environment and get
tips from Bulgaria about how to stop
blood-sucking vampires from feasting on
us but first most tourists will never
visit them but just a short distance
away from the Magnificent Pyramid of
Giza like sprawling slums stretching as
far as the eye can see millions of
people live in the shanty towns with no
running water no toilets no sewers and
no electricity the Arab world's most
populous nation has been going through
seismic changes since a popular uprising
Elstad former president hosni mubarak
two years ago but egyptians are finding
out that it's one thing to topple the
regime and another to lift people out of
poverty today the divide between the
haves and have-nots remains as great as
ever on TVs Muhammad Muji reports from
Cairo on what if anything the revolution
has brought Egyptians living in the
slums approximately half of kairos
population live in slums many of them
have moved here from rural areas and had
to build their own shelters on the
city's periphery these shanty towns have
few or no basic services such as
electricity or wastewater systems
my serve bottled sorrow will mere the
sewage is everywhere it just runs down
the slope no one from the government
wants to know when an official comes by
he doesn't even set foot in the
neighborhood he just stands at the end
of the street holy [ __ ] it's a disaster
truefire effluent seeps into every where
the maccrimmon's oh look at the ground
it's really soft but things can get a
lot worse but they can make whole houses
collapse I wish I'd this mukham des arc
AR sudoku law and if they ask at all
it's only after disasters already
happened with biggest alpha a hugger
wearables then they say we should have
done this all that but now adays they
don't even take us off a look that's
Allie cutter you look at it look on how
you was just stand at the end of the
street from there you can't see what's
happening liberally no masala Bolivar
shedder was just how do you begin with
some go money is extremely tight the
residents here have to buy water for
washing in the absence of water mains it
has to be carried home in containers
Master bas container costs 10 Egyptian
dollars so each load of washing cost the
equivalent of one euro ten cents leaving
us with the equivalent of twenty cents
for cooking and eating Wilma guided
we've been living here for nine years
and we're drowning in wastewater I have
to sleep on the ground and I always end
up soaked we can't even sleep for the
scorpions and snakes and things whenever
we go to the authorities the police
chase us off vocal amara la macchina
good minako amelia smith machine
everyone here suffers but its worst for
families with small children this is
anything but a suitable environment for
children some parents even give their
children away hoping that quality of
life will be a little better elsewhere
how did I get nitrogen in a bit sit on
my body no six families live here well
this way up with Rob this is my nephew
son his father's always beating him for
playing in the effluent he doesn't
understand Donovan chimis I've even sent
my little daughter away she's just two
years old and I was afraid that she'd
get hurt by some of the vermin here the
authorities just give us excuses I like
we had a fire here recently they told us
to get the police the police wanted
papers from us and asked us to get
photos of the damage we did that but
whenever we inquired they'd say come
back tomorrow it was always the same
book we've been here for 25 years now no
consolation in Santa Monica dodging
the residents feel completely abandoned
they tried over and over to get the
authorities to do something for them but
many have now given up all hope hey LM
at the shield web Teague whenever
officials come they just push us aside
and ignore us they don't regard us as
humans only the inhabitants of the new
buildings are humans we can't even leave
the area to go to work yeah Mel what a
hot dish of a Ahaggar yeah I'm better I
live here without water without
transportation with no sewage system
nothing not even apartment nothing baby
what I did in my book the man comes
every day to make sure the wastewater
doesn't back up
oh no everything's wrecked the doors to
the rooms are broken waters gotten into
the walls some of them have collapsed
and five times a week someone has to
come to make sure it flows away in the
right direction some people give him
what they can the vermin stop people
from sleeping properly and walls
collapse and kill people many of kairos
residents can't afford to live in new
apartment buildings while more than 7
million people live in the slums in the
megacity many flats stand empty the
inhuman living conditions have hardly
changed since Hosni Mubarak's departure
next Australia's not the first place
that you would think of heading in
search of all things Scottish but once a
year a small town in New South Wales
turns tartan overnight and all those
looking to celebrate their ties to the
motherland gather their cloud dust out
of their kilts and bust out the bagpipes
and as Christina Pollard reports you
don't have to be Scottish to join in the
celebrations list and the sound of
swirling bagpipes you'd be forgiven for
thinking it's another day in the
Highlands of Scotland
this is bundanoon in the New South Wales
Southern Highlands and once a year this
sleepy village is transformed into the
mythical town of Brigadier
plans from far and wide turn the town
into the biggest highland gathering in
the southern hemisphere as the story
goes the village of Brigadoon appears
for 24 hours once every 100 years before
disappearing again into the mists of
time every April for the past 34 years
thousands of people have made the
pilgrimage to bundanoon to watch the
street parade and traditional Highland
Games and grab a we slice of Scotland in
the process we changed the name of the
station to Brigadoon we team the name of
the tone to Brigadoon and if wandering
over night becomes Brigadoon for 12
months we were gone and then all of a
sudden but could come and we are ready
to entertain the public with our version
of Brigadoon but this version is a
Scottish ale and gathering to second me
throughout the day for a thoroughly
Scottish experience more than 20 pipe
bands march from the village centre to
the local sports ground this isn't a
competition this is a place for a pipe
band to come along and do what they do
best play the pipes and entertain the
public so no Highland gathering would be
complete without the pipes and the
Parramatta RSL contingent is one of many
that practice long into the night so
that everything is perfect for the big
day they love playing the pipes they
love getting in the uniform and the
atmosphere down here is fantastic
visitors are officially welcome to
Brigadoon by the chieftain of the day
the role of Tipton is basically to lead
the people in celebrating
not just Scotland and Scottish tradition
but the community this is a community
gathering the event has developed such a
tradition that second and third
generations of families are now enjoying
the Brigadoon experience I've been to
every Brigadoon the whole 35 just love
the place you know I love coming down
here and enjoying it and the atmosphere
is great and the music's great I now
have got all these family pushing me
along I was in church of the van
initially but my daughter's taking that
over and between her and my son he's in
charge of the drumming she's in charge
of hiking and now put three grandkids
I'll be back next year here is one be
the same without Brigadoon is all about
highland games with the spectators and
the participants from the traditional to
the net so tradition
a highlight is the bundanoon stones of
manhood based on the Malaysian stones of
manhood from Scotland this test of
strength speed and agility sees tartan
Warriors lifting massive sand stone
balls five stones 100 kilograms up to
165 kilograms object pick up the ball
put the sign soon ball on top of the
vinyl and the one who completes all five
in the cookers time is the winner and no
Highland gathering would be complete
without a haggis burger
here's proof I'm just enjoying the
holiday it's quite charmed
highland dancing is fake 56 tall it's
just nice people nice people you don't
have to be Scottish to come here you
know we are welcome everybody you know
as I said to somebody don't get your bum
off the beach at Bondi and come to plug
it in just as magically as it appeared
the day is done and the mythical
Brigadoon slips quietly away for another
high up in the Premier Li mountains of
Tajikistan farmers livelihoods are at
stake the former Soviet Republican one
of the poorest nations in Central Asia
is battling the problem of over grazing
this is bad for the animals and their
owners but it's also bad for the land
over grazing means that the sheep and
cows eat the plants right down to their
roots leaving nothing to hold soil in
place and in the process making their
land vulnerable to landslides now the
United Nations is trying to change that
with the help of one village un TVs Luis
patron has more after a long and
bitterly cold winter spring arrives in
the Premier Li mountains renewing its
pastures at this time of year the
village women and children are normally
busy tending their animals and taking
them to graze in nearby pastures but not
the people around the village of Jirga
toll this year they are experimenting
with a new approach all their animals
are taken to pastures some 12 kilometres
away their herds days in newly built
stables that protect them from the cold
spring rain at a time when the newborn
lambs are most vulnerable here a small
team of herders takes care of the
animals in spring when summer arrives
the herd will travel to graze in distant
pastures before returning again in
autumn
the construction of the stables was part
of a sustainable land management project
supported by the UN University unu the
united nations environment programme
unep and the global environment facility
nav elena petrova is a researcher from
you and you in jurgita the key issue has
turned out to be access to pastures
degradation of pastors in surrounding
the settlement areas has been a key
problem it was clear to the project team
that keeping the animals near the
village during springtime had led to
over grazing of the young grasses on the
accessible pastures leaving bare land
exposed to erosion by rains and wind
construction of stables which can host
livestock earlier in their season
outside the villages is hoping to reduce
pressure upon those surrounding pastures
surrounding the villages local women
like Miley chania rova embraced this
approach as it relieves them from the
drudgery of tending their animals hi
hello it's wonderful that this table
sway built and this means we have fewer
chores watch it village women now have
time to process wool and so close the
work provides an additional source of
income and keeps a traditional craft
alive have them I roma Roma I from
ancient times we have learned how to
reduce the health costs from our
great-grandmother's grandmothers and
mothers I'm now showing the younger
generation how to do it so they can
learn hockey Baja as summer arrives
villagers are leaving to set up camp in
the distance summer pastures
this time mullah mourad and his
neighbors are travelling by truck on a
recently improved road things have been
changing here and a lot of people are
traveling to the summer pastures the
road is wet so the villagers can save
the transporter belongings without
heating stones the improvement of the
road which is also part of the UN you
and unit project has enabled people to
leave earlier in the season giving the
fields around the village a longer time
to regenerate herders also welcomed the
improved safety as the road allows them
to reach healthcare facilities more
quickly in case of emergencies while the
road brought considerable benefits to
the community it also has had some
unintended consequences it has made it
easier for people to come and harvest
firewood and take it back in their
vehicles the community took action to
remedy the situation yucca wannabes good
although we need to transport coal and
other important things we didn't want to
destroy nature because the vegetation
was disappearing we decided to limit the
length of their own we Holloway that's
why the road ends here it was built only
halfway to the summer pastures from this
point on people must walk and carry
their belongings on animals for several
hours
beyond improving your own living
conditions villages are also committed
to safeguard their fragile environment
that has sustained their lives for
centuries
it's no exaggeration to say that the
award-winning Venezuelan artist Pedro
bricio has dedicated most of his 82
years to exploring form and space in his
sculptures now an exhibition in Caracas
is showcasing his work the title of the
show is back to the Tresh hold or
entrance Catalina Oh made us from teva
Valley Venezuela went to talk to him
about his work
air terminal umbral threshold is an
essentially spatial concept empathy ala
el umbral a threshold is a transition to
another space a room a building hey como
lo n through Z Allah Allah Allah alta
loma la casa
level duda in our thorough space plays a
very important role in this sculpture
when you work with sheet iron or dealing
with an entirely different sense of
space different than what you'd have
with a sculpture in stone or wood where
the mass is pretty much predefined and
forms one solid shape metrica as former
roommates but with a sculpture made of
sheet iron you can integrate the
surrounding space and refer to it
authorial uno uno de una where you can
reach your hand through it la cultura
and that creates a real sense of
three-dimensional space magia de Cirey
loose oreo
I will cut repeatedly I've achieved a
kind of harmony between what I build and
what I feel yo y lo que hemos film into
a film know if i don't see my work as an
essentially scientific work i let myself
be guided by intuition emotion and the
tension in the material young fella
material tambien
so yea though I think geometrically and
abstractly but for example I like to use
the plant kingdom as my starting point
hey party LOL oh they love it they love
a hit assume the molar so I admire the
spatial sense of vegetation the way
leaves and trees grow and form a
sculpture that can withstand all the
storms and they do it while expanding
upward vertically has that beautiful
saying goes trees die standing up for
more than that be a
and finally unless you've been living
under a rock you might have noticed that
vampires are huge courtesy of Hollywood
these heart throbs with fangs have
legions of teenage girls pining for
blood sucking romance but in Bulgaria
vampires are still of the traditional
type terrifying nightmarish creatures
that drain the life out of their victims
well now bulgarian anthropologists are
in a rush to record all the trusty
vampire slaying methods for future
generations Nova TV filed this report as
folklore would have it humans turn into
vampires if they're unlucky enough to be
bitten by one of the undead but some
folk stories say that only cruel people
become vampires for 20 years now
anthropologists sash kabisa renova has
been researching rituals and traditions
in northern Bulgari's reading region
vampires are at the heart of some of
them some beauty according to popular
belief people who died of unnatural
causes who died when they are very young
or very old can become vampires no this
relates to a need for life to have
defined boundaries brickell a Nova's new
horror
devata Turia it's unnatural for a young
person to die by becoming too old can
also result in your becoming a vampire
nahuatl trick no II prick there's also
an old belief that this trait can be
inherited vampires from Emma Bovary yay
we came across a case like that in the
village of gray debts where there is a
family whose name is goulash it was
believed that evil people rose from
their graves to inflict harm on other
individuals or frequently an entire
village but also sertraline elite you
drop Apocrypha that they might have
heard something clattering on the roofs
appearing at night causing trouble
immerse smartness sometimes animals died
or people got the feeling that they were
suffocating you meet the hora folklore
says that a man can become a vampire if
he has never been injured in his life
the curfuffle chill your gitch quote
from you better no woman told us about a
case like that in the village of jug
each it related to her grandfather who
they thought had become a vampire sport
yaakov imperious oh if every night a
domestic animal died this witch in
stokerton then the mayor of the village
allowed the grave to be exhumed mate
there isn't a shoot-first that has
happened at the beginning of the 20th
century in 1902 disculpe the body of the
dead man hadn't started to decompose the
Saros lager but also visa be the cheeks
of The Departed were pink his nails and
hair had grown and his body was lying on
one side in the confidence that never
for coffee a toga versa GoPro Belize's
they hammered a spike through the body
poured boiling wine over it vint ova
notch in zurich rakov on an MA they
spittin this was the way they stopped
the vampires activities and put an end
to the damage he was doing menasha
circle the buddha prick retain
boy janka marine OVA is one of the few
remaining people who still observe the
tradition of ensuring that the dead
don't turn into vampires
kissing nope sorry mr. we put bulbs of
garlic inside the coffin and then we put
candles in the corners we use the last
candle to make a cross over the dead man
crabbiness smoothly hayley nickel you
three women used to go and put flags on
the departed's body but we don't do it
these days because we cannot find any so
we use paper instead asses what do you
do with the spindle the other was a mile
a minute today mr. we insert the spindle
in three different places with the sharp
in downwards soft little one spindle for
each bulb of garlic there and that will
stop in becoming a vampire yes hey there
yes our grandmothers believe that so we
believe to rock with wash pessoa roof
progress is in some villages in this
region a nail is hammered into people's
doorsteps system at the Jade you know
they believe that it will ward off the
danger of them becoming a vampire of
Imperials funny nowadays with the
resurgence of vampire movies vampires
have become part of youth culture again
but popular beliefs about hunting them
are slowly disappearing as time goes on
mr. tough sip or where things are
changing more and more you should sit
people are forgetting these beliefs did
not polini the generation that grew up
before World War two and no and preserve
these traditions will pass away is
possible with each other and that's all
we've got time for this week thanks so
much for joining us remember you can
watch this show or any past show by
heading to DW de / world stories I'll
leave you now with this week's picks of
the world see you next time
you